what's up
hey how are you
actually
oh
hey mark page here white house
no no no no it's full it's just awful
yeah yeah it's full cups
yeah so we're pulling it off thank you
i'm gonna be sure you're rolling all
right
thank you so much
flag
sure
is
is
okay
foreign
sure
oh
boys
sure
so
um
is
yeah a number of kids
you
oh
should
we have a human oriented press briefing
thank you
yes
thank you
uh
um
um
juniors
hi everyone
okay just a couple of items for you at
the top
president biden believes that the surge
in gun violence and violent crime
that has affected communities across the
country over the last year and a half is
unacceptable
that's why his administration is moving
decisively to act with a whole of
government approach
today the biden-harris administration is
announcing a comprehensive strategy
to combat violent crime and gun violence
that targets the crime itself
implements preventative measure measures
that are proven to reduce violent crime
and attacks root causes
including by addressing the flow
firearms used to commit crimes
combined this plan will stem the flow of
firearms used to commit violence
including by holding rogue firearm
dealers accountable for violating
federal laws
support local law enforcement with
federal tools and resources to help
address violent crime
invest in evidence-based community
violence interventions
expand summer programming employment
opportunities
and other services and support for teen
for teenagers and young adults
and help formerly incarcerated
individuals successfully re-enter their
communities
one of the key elements of this strategy
is helping state and local governments
fight gun violence
and violent crime in their communities
through the historic funding levels
in the american rescue plan today's
strategy builds on
that by providing further guidance for
states and cities to expand their
ability to improve public safety in
their communities
and we've already seen examples of what
is happening around the country
in philadelphia mayor kenny is using
funding from aarp to address gun
violence
reform and improve the police department
and invest in violent interruption
programs
in albuquerque mayor keller plans to
spend 3 million dollars to expand the
city's
gunshot detection system and millions
more to recruit police officers and
refurbish station houses
in akron ohio mayor horrigan has
proposed 20 million dollars to reduce
community and youth violence
through employment training and
opportunities as well as recreation
assets i'd also note uh today obviously
the president will speak to all of this
later this afternoon
today the vice president will hold a
listening session with leading civil
rights and voting rights groups
from across the country following the
senate vote on the for the people act
just yesterday
the meeting builds on the vice
president's work to bring together a
national coalition on voting rights
to promote voter registration and
engagement engagement
among americans across the country from
greenville south carolina to atlanta
georgia
to protect our fundamental right to vote
she will drive the message that the
fight is not over
and that the president and the
administration remain committed to
ensuring
that all americans have access to the
ballot finally i do have one more thing
tomorrow the president will travel to
raleigh north carolina some of you may
be on that trip
as our administration continues to work
to continue encouraging
vaccinations across the country ensuring
every american knows just how to ensure
it is easy to get vaccinated while he's
there he will highlight the importance
of getting vaccinated and kick off a
community canvassing event
at the green road park community center
in raleigh he will also tour a mobile
vaccination
unit and meet with frontline workers and
grassroots volunteers
who are the boots on the ground working
to get people in their communities
vaccinated alex why don't you kick us
off jen first off the vice president's
office just announced that she'll be
visiting the border friday what can you
tell us about the
visit and you have in the past defended
the decision not to visit the border by
anyone
really like by president biden or vice
president harrison
what's behind the sort of challenge sure
first i think many of you may have seen
it but just to reiterate the specific
details uh the vice president will
travel
to el paso texas on friday she will be
accompanied by department of homeland
security secretary allen yorkis
earlier this year as you all know the
president asked the vice president
to oversee our diplomatic efforts to
address the root causes of migration
from el salvador to guatemala and
honduras and as a part of this work she
recently traveled to guatemala and
mexico last month
to have those discussions and uh
this trip to the border on friday will
uh be a part of this effort
i will note that i've also said here
from this podium and she has also said
that
when it was the right time she may go to
visit the border and so
uh this trip on friday which is being
done in coordination with the department
of homeland security secretary mayorkas
is of course
joining her on this trip uh you know and
and the planning and timing of it was
done in coordination with them
uh is part of the coordinated effort
between her
office her work the department of
homeland security the department of
health and human services
to continue to address the root causes
and work in coordination
to get the situation under control sure
and then on voting rights
the president's statement yesterday said
he'll have more to say on this next week
can you give us a sense of what we
should expect from the president on
voting rights and you also have said
that there are other avenues for
protecting voting rights what do those
look like
then i'm going to take another stab at
this i know you've been asked this five
different ways
but does the president believe that the
filibuster
is defending the filibuster is worth
more and more important than protecting
voting rights
well first let me say as the vice
president said yesterday
and i'll just reiterate uh the fight uh
and to improve and expand access to
voting
is far from over and the president as he
noted in his statement yesterday and as
you just touched on
uh will be speaking to this next week
and this is a continuation of his
efforts to use the bully pulpit to
elevate this issue
as he did just last week when he marked
uh juneteenth and also as he did in
tulsa oklahoma just a few weeks
before that uh so i expect you we'll
have more to preview as we get closer
but i can tell
you that what you should expect to hear
from him is
that there are many ways to work across
the country
with activists with states with
legislators
using every lever at our disposal to
expand access
improve access to voting for people
across the country we'll talk about some
of the ways
that he wants to continue to do that
he'll also reiterate his view that it's
a fundamental right
and that people across the country
should be able to exercise that to
decide
who they want to be their mayor who they
want to be their congressman who they
want to be
their president and everybody who
supports democracy who supports equality
who supports justice
should be supporting uh improvements to
our voting rights laws
one more last one on this conversation
around crime how should the american
people
measure success for president biden on
crime
um should they be looking for a
reduction in crime in their localities
or
i mean what exactly is he aiming for and
announcing these new policies today
well that certainly is the goal of
course uh but i would say alex that uh
what the president has watched closely
is that there has been
of course an increase in violent crime
gun violence specifically in a lot of
communities
over the last 18 months he's obviously
taken a number of steps over the past
couple of months to
work to address that this is a
continuation of that in his view
and part of that is empowering uh local
uh
police communities and making sure that
local communities have the funding they
need to
to support efforts by the local police
it also means taking steps to address
the prevalence of gun violence across
the country so of course his
objective is to uh take steps steps
he can do as the president of the united
states using the tools he has at his
disposal to
empower local communities get them the
resources they need and ensure we're
putting laws in place that reduce gun
violence go ahead thanks jeff
can you tell us a little bit more about
what the vice president will be doing at
the border is she visiting a detention
center or a facility for
migrant children and how much access
will the press
have to whatever sites she tours while
she's there
they're all great questions obviously
they just made this announcement i'm
sure they will have more details to
share with you i just don't have any
more to share with you at this
particular moment on what she'll be
doing specifically there
um and then can you tell us a little bit
more about this decision uh
for the uscc's website domains used by
iranian state tv what what led to that
decision and why now it's a department
of justice decision
and action so i point you to them is
there any concern
that this could hamper negotiations uh
over iran's nuclear program uh we are
still at the point uh
and in those discussions we just
finished the sixth round obviously
uh all of the negotiators are back in
their capitals having discussions as
is appropriate uh we see advantage to us
in moving toward a diplomatic solution
we hope others
who have seats at the table do as well
uh but again this was an action by the
department of justice
not uh not coordinated with other
aspects of our
negotiations and then what can you tell
us about the talks that took place on
the hill yesterday
over the bipartisan infrastructure
proposal
that were those fruitful discussions and
where does that go from here is the
president going to be hosting
any of those senators here at the white
house in the coming days
if we continue to make progress in these
discussions then the president looks
forward to welcoming members to the
white house before the end of the week
uh we'll see there were a couple rounds
there were two rounds of discussions
yesterday and i know you're all aware of
this or many of you cover this closely
but
there was one in the afternoon there was
another one last night additional
progress was made
last night this afternoon steve
burchetti louisa terrell
brian deese are all back up on the hill
right about now
having continued discussions about the
path forward
that's one track where we are moving
forward on these bipartisan negotiations
and we assess as we conclude each rounds
what the next step should be so again if
we make progress
and if we assess that that it is the
appropriate time to bring these
officials uh these elected officials to
the white house the president looks
forward to doing that
go ahead thank you jen so about today's
announcement why is the vice president
visiting the border this week
when earlier this month she dismissed a
trip like that
saying it would be a grand gesture she
also said um
in an interview with nbc that she would
be open to going to the border if it was
an appropriate time she said that after
she said that so that's important
context
right an important context i've got the
nbc interview right here
she was talking about how she hasn't
been on the border she hasn't been to
europe
either so does she think that these two
things are the same
uh and again uh peter i think she also
said in the same interview
that she would be open to going to the
border at an appropriate time and what
i'm conveying to you
is that uh well as a part of her
assignment she has of course hosted a
number of bilateral engagements she's
visited uh the northern triangle uh
she's taken made a number of
announcements about how to
address root causes that she's going was
going to assess with the department of
homeland security and with the
administration when it was the
appropriate time to go
and i will note that we're at this point
in part because we've made
a great deal of progress and if you look
just to a couple of months ago
when six thousand children were in
border patrol facilities we're now at
the point where there's
far less than a thousand if you look to
just a couple of months ago
when there were children who were
waiting in border patrol facilities for
more than a hundred hours and they were
certainly overcrowded uh now it's less
than 30 hours
in april there were 22 000 kids in hhs
facilities and now that number is 14
000. is there still more work to do
absolutely
that's the purview of secretary marcus
but it's important every component of
our government is coordinated was it
important for
the white house to have her seen at the
border before
former president trump has a trip there
next week
uh we made an assessment within our
government about when it was an
appropriate time for her to go to the
border
and then just one about the crime today
i you mentioned
expanding the crime prevention role yes
um but there is a lot of crime in big
cities uh how do you reject much of it
caused by gun violence
would you agree yes so how do you ex how
do you
reduce gun violence by expanding
employment opportunities
including summer jobs for young people
well first there's several components of
this proposal
one of them is an initial set of actions
on gun violence
or an additional set i should say of
steps on gun violence which
the president feels are important to get
guns off the streets
make sure they are not in the hands of
people illegally many of whom are
playing a role in violent crime across
the country that's part of his objective
he also wants to provide as we've seen
has been effective in communities across
the country
incentives and alternatives for young
people in communities uh where that has
shown to be an effective step
so it's the thought there basically that
somebody some criminal
who has been committing crimes with
limited interruption or interference
from police for the last couple weeks or
months
is going to stop this easy life of crime
if
they have a summer job well i think the
president believes that we shouldn't and
we shouldn't allow
access to guns to those criminals who
are
currently illegally biling them from
some dealers across the country and
part of his announcement is taking steps
to do exactly that but part of his
announcement is also
ensuring their specific guidance to uh
communities across the country to ensure
that they have
funding to get more community police
around the country something that was
supported by
the american jobs plan that was
supported that was voted into law by
democrats just a couple of months ago
some might say that
the other party was for defunding the
police i'll let others say that but
that's a piece go ahead what you can see
there is a political calculation to
having the vice president
visit the border before donald trump
goes
and with a drum beat from republicans
who have counted the days
that she has not visited the border
isn't there a political decision
in the timing of this well kelly i would
say that we have no way to predict what
president former president trump
will say uh when he had when he goes to
the border uh we can only
guess um but uh i don't think our view
is that uh
the vice president making a trip to the
border with the secretary of homeland
security
to assess and take a look at progress
that's been made is going
to prevent or change what the former
president of the united states does when
he goes to the border in a couple days
oh go ahead do you have another question
but senators including senator tesner
are saying that they believe they're
at really the kind of razor edge a
moment with deciding the paid force
for infrastructure uh can they go
forward do you feel
that um there is the possibility of some
kind of a development within the next 24
hours would you agree that that sense of
the
timing and is there anything new that
the white house has
offered for paying for these uh
infrastructure programs that we have not
uh learned of from you before well
there's no question as you know it's
much easier to negotiate with congress
when they're in session
uh so we're certainly hoping to make
progress over the next couple of days
i'm not going to put it 24
48 there's a couple more days in the
week and we're hopeful to make progress
um if we see progress continue to be
made between our discussions with our
members of our senior team and members
then we look forward to welcoming
democrats and republicans here to the
white house to meet with the president
in terms of what we would offer the
president has offered a range of ways to
pay for these proposals and we've also
taken
we had so many options of how to pay for
these proposals we've even taken some of
our own proposals off the table
including uh ensuring that individual
individuals pay a higher rate for this
specific
civic negotiation and also uh raising
the corporate rate for this specific
negotiation even though we're keeping it
on the table for later on to be
very clear but the bottom line it's it's
pretty clear and simple to the president
uh the choice for him on the pay fors is
are you going to ask americans who are
just trying to go to work just trying to
drive their cars to work
drop their kids off at school to pay
more through the through a gas tax
or should should the wealthiest
americans pay what they owe in taxes
to him that's a pretty clear no-brainer
choice
that's part of the discussion though go
ahead back to the president's crime
prevention announcement today you've
noted that
violent crime has been up over the last
18 months and several years
so what specifically prompted the
president to come out and make this
announcement today
well there's a policy process that has
been underway for the last couple of
weeks and months even we've had a series
of announcements as you know
over the past several months on gun
violence prevention obviously there was
funding in the american
rescue plan to support keeping cops on
the street
and there are several components that
were just prepared to be announced
and you've made clear you're tackling
this you know as a gun issue
the president has urged congress to take
action on this we've seen very little
movement
on the hill it's been years since we've
seen sweeping gun reforms
out of washington uh what is the
president's message then to americans
who are
concerned about rising crime in their
communities in order to achieve
real progress do they have to wait for
congress to act
well the president would certainly like
to see congress act on universal
background checks on an assault weapons
ban a number of the pieces of
legislation that are currently
uh i shouldn't say working their way
through congress but are currently
alive in congress um but he's not going
to wait and
his message to the american people is
he's going to take steps
that he has the power to take as
president to reduce gun violence
to put in place measures that will
reduce the likelihood of criminals
having access to guns on the streets
there are authorities you have any
president has and he's going to take
steps to do that even as he pushes for
legislation to move forward
so beyond the announcements today he is
preparing or considering additional
steps that could
tackle some of these issues well i think
we're going to focus on the
announcements he's making today a lot of
which are on gun violence and
gun violence prevention measures i don't
have anything beyond that to preview but
there are some significant steps he's
certainly announcing this afternoon and
just one more question on how the
funding for all of this works
you're allowing state and local
governments to reallocate some of the
cobit 19
relief funds to hire more police
officers invest in other areas
uh to combat this rise in crime but when
republicans pitched
that idea to try and pay for for some
infrastructure plan
uh the white house said that money was
already allocated so what's what's the
difference well the money was always
allocated
in state and local authority as to state
and local governments one of the
authorities they could always have taken
was to ensure there were more cops on
the beat
more police in place and and that's
something we have always said was a part
of the plan and the proposal
i don't know why republicans oppose that
or why that would have prompted them to
vote against the package
go ahead just to follow up on mary's
first question
public safety can be a potent political
issue to what degree if any
has the politics played a role in the
decision to really try and get out in
front of things
today well the president has been very
consistent
in his views over the course of decades
um
he has never been for defunding the
police he has always been a supporter of
ensuring there are
that local community uh policing is
funded
and adequately supported uh by the
federal government
he's also been a long time advocate for
decades and leader on addressing gun
violence
so this is actually a continuity of his
uh leadership on these issues over the
course of decades now he has taken steps
since president
on each of these issues as well
including supporting funding proposing
funding in his own budget
for community policing and this is just
an opportunity to
put additional meat on the bones two
more quick ones you've answered this
before but just to
make sure i understand red lines in the
elusive search for
pay fors that are available to everybody
user fees on electric vehicles is that
in the same category as indexing the gas
tax from your guys perspective in these
negotiations yes
we are not for a ford f-150 tax i'm not
sure why others are
good um and then quickly given the tempo
of some of the taliban offensives that
we've seen
in afghanistan um are there contingency
plans
at work right now to you know troops out
faster or
perhaps more importantly embassy
officials folks that we plan
the u.s plan to keep on the ground if
they advance
much quicker than perhaps was initially
thought well first i would say that our
department of defense is uh
overseeing an orderly withdrawal of our
troops from afghanistan and
doing that at a pace that in their view
will keep ensure their safety
and ensure we are doing it in a way
that's effective and
in a coordinated manner with the
government um i will say that
um well in general we are seeing
elevated attacks
on dsf and afghan government versus a
year ago
we have not seen an increase in attacks
on our military or presence since
february 2020
and we also assess that had we not begun
to draw down
violence would have increased against us
as well after may 1st because
that was what the taliban was clearly
conveying
so the status quo in our view was not an
option
in terms of personnel
and others on the ground that's
certainly something that our state
department and our team takes very
seriously and assesses
uh whether there is a need to take any
additional action um
and i would certainly refer defer to
them on any
additional preview they do on that front
go ahead thank you john
um we understand that the administration
plans to replace the fannie mae and
freddie mac's federal regulator
uh after the supreme court ruling um
that has now made it easier for the
president to install this preferred
overseer do you have a comment on that
that's correct uh given the supreme
court ruling this morning but i don't
have uh
okay um and any comment on the uh
on russia firing uh warning shots and
and dropping bombs
um to chase the british warship uh out
of the waters moscow
now claims that in the black sea that
they claim uh it belongs to russia i
would point you to the british we don't
have any more comment on it from here
and one question on uh voting rights
we've been kind of talking to
a lot of voting rights and civil rights
activists who are saying
that the president isn't just simply
doing enough uh
on the issue and is uh betraying black
voters who actually helped him get him
get into the office by not doing
absolutely everything he can
um and he's instead spending his time
negotiating
infrastructure with republicans how
would you respond to that criticism
who's saying that a lot of uh civil
rights uh activists and voting activists
like who we've spoken to several groups
and outfits i mean i can
reach out to you with names after the
briefing sure
that sounds good okay go ahead thanks
jim
um a number of lawmakers have asked the
administration to
extend the federal moratory modulations
which expires at the end of the month
is that something the administration is
considering and why or why not
sure well let me first say that that
would be a decision uh
the decision to extend the eviction
moratorium will be made by the cdc
based on public health conditions and we
certainly wouldn't get ahead of their
assessment
as you know the the more the eviction
moratorium expires on june 30th 30th
hence i think your question
it was always intended to be temporary
and the president remains focused on
ensuring that americans who are
struggling
through no fault of their own have an
off-ramp once it ends hence we've also
worked to take additional steps to
ensure people are getting the support
they need to stay in their homes
whether they are renters or homeowners
but we'd certainly
defer to the cdc on their decision and
their timeline go ahead
thanks jen uh the miami police chief art
acevedo expressed
concern disappointment that uh his
association wasn't invited to the
discussion
he uh his association represents dozens
of the largest
uh city police forces the major cities
chief association
i just wanted to ask why the group
wasn't invited
considering the rule that they would
likely be part of it
well i think as we were putting together
the round table that the president is uh
taking part in today we
tried to have a diverse group of
individuals representing a range of
interests from across the country
who have all played an active and vital
role
in addressing crime and crime prevention
across the country
it is not meant to diminish anyone
including the individual you mentioned
and i'm sure we will be
closely engaged with them and others who
are not a part of this roundtable one
more question
the crime and um gun prevention effort
um this effort involves redirecting some
of the relief aid
to these veterans it gives wide latitude
for spending that money in certain areas
but the bible administration largely
opposed redirecting
relief funds for infrastructure projects
there were some
limited exceptions water and sewer but
why
was it not okay for infrastructure or
limited for infrastructure but it is
more okay for this
here i think this is similar to the
question mary just asked i mean it has
always been
the case that ensuring funding was used
by state and local authorities to keep
cops on the beat
uh was always a part of what was allowed
uh
in in the parameters of the spending and
that is something that a number of
communities as i outlined at the
beginning
did take the steps to do so this is just
giving additional guidance on how to use
the funds
go ahead thanks jen uh on the meeting
later today
uh between uh chuck schumer nancy pelosi
and white house officials
what is the white house's message to
them going to be with regards to the
infrastructure talks so you're going to
insist on continuing
going down the bipartisan route or is
this going to be decision point where
if they may sort of kick the tires and
go ahead with reconciliation on that
well we've always seen this or seen this
for some time i should say not always um
as a two-track strategy
right so there are different discussions
and negotiations happening today
one track the american jobs plan or big
components of it
uh is a part of the infrastructure
negotiations that
we're discussing steve roshetti louisa
terrell bryant's right now with members
who are part of that
bipartisan discussion later tonight is a
discussion that will also include
shalonna young also includes susan rice
and others that's a part
a discussion in part about the budget
reconciliation process the second track
and that track
will include the american families plan
and components that are not a part of
the negotiations so
we've been saying two tracks today is an
example of two tracks actually moving
forward at one time in one day
which track is moving more smoothly
right now
they're both moving at a rapid pace um
you know they're both moving we we know
that
um one we're we're at a later stage
obviously in the bipartisan negotiations
you all know that
and obviously we want to make progress
over the next couple of days we're in an
earlier stage of the budget
reconciliation progress
process that's because that's how that
process works but it's important to keep
both tracks going
there's one more for you on i just
wanted to follow up if you had any
answer from yesterday what about whether
president biden discussed interest rates
with fed chairman powell and
other financial regulators i just the
interest rates as you know are
under the purview of the federal reserve
i gave you an overview of what was
discussed in the meeting and don't have
anything else to add to that
on the for the thanksgiving on the
fourth people act uh that you said this
week that would be the fight
of this presidency the president said
last night the fight is not over
now that the senate has put itself on
the record how do you see this fight
playing out in 117 congress on the floor
it's going to be one on the floor before
the end of this conference
we'll see i don't think we can assess
that quite yet and i think what's
important to know
is that the president's going to keep
fighting for federal legislation the
vice president is going to keep fighting
for federal legislation
leader schumer and others have also made
clear i think on the floor last night
they're going to continue to look for
paths forward
we will we will see what that looks like
but we're still assessing that in the
coming days
uh what the president will also talk
about though next week is
uh not that fight but also what we can
do
uh in states around the country what we
can do through a range of the
authorities that the federal government
has
because for all of these our objective
is to make it easier to vote make it
more accessible to vote
and there's a lot of ways to do that
even as we're continuing to fight for
federal legislation i'll ask you another
question about the border
you said that a lot of a great deal of
progress
has been made border patrol statistics
show something close to 900 000
interactions or encounters on the
southwest border so far this fiscal year
170 000 odd per month the last three
months
is that where you're measuring progress
you spoke of the
unaccompanied minors but what about the
the influx of people
the vice president was tasked with the
diplomatic efforts there has that been
successful and how are you measuring
that success
well first i think the vice president
has made a number of announcements about
coordinated efforts with countries in
the region
in the northern triangle through her
leadership
in that area and we'll we'll be able to
assess over time what it looks like in
terms of migration
numbers i was pointing to the fact that
a couple of months ago we were looking
at
very overcrowded border patrol
facilities we were looking at
kids waiting for far too long in those
facilities and
there being a timeline of getting kids
to vetted
family members that wasn't up to our um
up to our bar um there has certainly
been progress made in that regard but
the work is ongoing uh go ahead
thanks jen my colleagues are reporting
that the u.s intelligence community
concluded last week that the government
of afghanistan could collapse as soon as
six months
after the american withdrawal is
completed
what is your reaction to that and do you
think that would also
factor into speeding up an evacuation
especially for afghans who helped the us
well let me first say on sivs on special
immigrant visas and these are
individuals
who have played an incredibly courageous
role in helping
the united states at various times over
the course of our recent history
we are processing and getting people out
at a record pace
we are working with congress right now
to streamline some of the requirements
that slow this process down and we're
doing the kind of extensive planning for
potential evacuation
should that become necessary so we're
continuing to evaluate
what our options are there continuing to
take steps forward and certainly we want
to take every step we can take
from the federal government to treat all
these courageous individuals as they
deserve
is there a reaction on that intelligence
community's assessment at all that the
government could collapse within six
months
the u.s withdrawing i don't have any
more assessment beyond the intelligence
community
afghanistan yes as you know
uh president will be here on friday
while
president abdullah
our visiting washington dc taliban still
continued their attacking all over
afghanistan
do you think that president boyd and
committed to
stronger long-term support for afghan
people
especially afghan military because
afghan people has a high expectation
from this
i would say i don't anticipate the
timeline for withdrawal is not going to
change
um by september uh which of course is
overseen by our department of defense
a part of their discussion on friday
will certainly be the president
reiterating his commitment
uh to uh work uh with the government of
afghanistan to continue to provide
humanitarian support over the horizon
security
uh us you know work um that that he
committed to when he made this
announcement and i'm sure they'll
discuss this during their meeting on
friday
uh go ahead francesca i've got a couple
i've got a couple for you sure firstly
on the on the vice president's trip to
the border why does the white house view
this
as the appropriate time for that visit
uh well i think francesca the decision
on the timing was made in coordination
with the department of homeland security
as we've said from the beginning
we didn't want to have anyone visit at a
time where it'd be disruptive to
efforts and progress being made on the
ground but they made that assessment and
she had said just a few weeks ago that
she'd be open to going to the border
if at the appropriate time and earlier
today the white house announced that 15
jurisdictions would
participate in its community violence
intervention program
do you anticipate that list expanding to
include other cities like
kansas city which is grappled with gun
violence and has been engaged with the
white house on this issue
that's a great question and you're right
that it was 15 cities that we announced
or 15 jurisdictions that we announced
uh this morning those jurisdictions uh
step or we will announce i guess i
should say later this afternoon
uh as they step forward to join uh the
collaborative because they're committed
to using these strategies as a tool to
reducing the scourge of gun violence
um they have also designated a portion
of their american rescue plan
state and local funding or another
source of public funding to support cvi
efforts
and have committed to city leadership
and infrastructure such as leading local
efforts
through an office of neighborhood safety
we're calling for more cities
to follow these jurisdictions lead and
certainly we'd welcome engagement
and a desire to follow those trends as
well lastly is the white house worried
that its non-infrastructure agenda is
being
stymied to the point that it could have
a negative impact on democrats competing
in next year's elections
you mean our budget reconciliation
process we're meeting about today
no i'm talking about a 15 minimum wage
voting rights there's
ongoing disputes over child care other
elements of the families plan
immigration reform there's a there's
there's a number of different things
i will say that the american families
plan is a part of the
budget reconciliation discussion and
process that's in historic investment in
child care and community college and
universal pre-k a number of areas that
are a huge
huge priority to the president as well
as many democrats
i think ultimately i'm not going to
assess 18 months from the midterm
elections what that looks like but
the the most important topics on the
american minds of the american people
are
covid and the economy and we're
certainly moving forward on all fronts
go ahead thank you jen um first question
on
afghanistan um the afghani leaders who
are coming to meet with the president
on friday are going to want specifics
about u.s support secure the governments
and human rights
games that have been brought in our last
20 years there
can the president guarantee that those
gains won't be lost
the president can guarantee that we will
continue to support
humanitarian assistance support for
progress human rights progress that's
been made on the ground and
a range of uh investments the united
states have made that we've already
committed to continuing has you
determined
how much money that is needed over the
course of time that's going to be done
on kind of a year by year assessment
sort of in the next year or then is
there any sort of estimate there
beyond our budget i don't have anything
more beyond our budget
on crime i just wanted to ask quickly um
if you could
give us any details about who helped
shape the president's crime plan
you know were there was there impact
input from various activists
perhaps from the floyd family uh
it was certainly uh driven of course by
the president of the united states who
oversees all of our policies here and
driven by policy leaders within the
government from
susan rice cedric richmond a number
there's obviously economic components
gene sperling brian dece
and they certainly do assess and engage
with a range of activists
and leaders around the country but i
don't have any more detail to read out
for you
go ahead oh yeah just really quickly um
on the vice president
there's a lot of discussion today about
the vice president's role in immigration
but i wasn't wondering if you could
outline any of her involvement in the
last
sure moments on infrastructure a a
different
topic that is sort of in the closing
stage right now is
has her portfolio there sort of gotten
lower as
other things have risen or can you just
give us the sort of state of play
sure well i would say that um the
negotiations are primarily
being led at a staff level by louisa
terrell steve roshetti and brian diese
and
again if we're at the point where we've
made enough progress
the president will invite them here and
i'm sure the vice president would be a
part of that but they've really been led
at the staff level over the past couple
of days and
if there's calls that weren't uh the
vice president or the president making
certainly they would make them but uh
that's really what the action where the
action has been over the last several
days go ahead
thanks uh just to follow my colleague's
question about the eviction moratorium
sure there's some reporting that there's
a one month extension that's gonna
come out pretty soon i know you said you
don't like ahead of the cdc but the cdc
is punching all of our questions back to
you
so is there anything confusing sorry
anything you can tell us about whether a
one-month extension is to be expected
i don't have anything i can uh confirm
for you from here today
okay and then on guns all advocates are
saying there should be a guns are is
that something that's still being
considered by the white house one person
that's responsible and
spearheading this work on gun reform the
president is responsible
go ahead yes thank you jen for some
months
lawmakers of both parties have been uh
asking the administration
to uh prohibit polysilicon
from coming into the country from china
because it's uh being made in xinjiang
it's a key
material as you may know for solar
panels
so is there some concern that
prohibiting that from china
could hurt the president's net zero
goals
or what are you looking at it doing in
regards to this from the human rights
perspective
well first let me say that in cornwall
uh just two weeks ago uh g7 countries
committed
to ensuring that global supply chains
are free from the use of forced labor
uh and there which was a significant
statement and agreement among g7
countries
and so as a part of that you can expect
that the united states will continue to
hold
those who engage in forced labor
accountable and that we will continue to
remove goods made from
local forced labor from our supply
chains
as you also know and i think this is the
root of your question
we also remain committed to making
progress uh
internationally glo domestically and
internationally
on addressing the climate crisis um but
we think we can certainly do both
i don't have anything yet to announce uh
as it relates to
specific um uh products or substances i
should say that are planned um
but uh we'll see if we have more on that
in the coming days
oh okay great we have to gather for the
event thanks everyone so much have a
great day see you tomorrow
[Music]
you